hey guys how's it going so the apple
event just concluded and some of those
highlights of the event are the air pods
it's apple's wireless headphones we've
also got the iphone 7 the iphone 7 plus
and the apple watch series 2. so let's
just get right into
the entire event to start this whole
event off
i was freaking out i was super excited i
decided to do a live stream of this
event if you wanna watch the full live
stream you can it's two hours of me
probably just getting real rowdy so the
whole live stream starts off with tim
cook and james gordon in a car doing the
whole carpool karaoke thing james is
driving him around san francisco to take
him to the apple event and then at some
point pharrell hops in the car and it
was just it was strange and amazing and
just just so absolutely perfect and it
was probably one of my favorite intros
to an apple event i think ever so that
whole stunt was because cook says that
new episodes of carpool karaoke will
debut on apple music early next year so
that's kind of cool let's talk about why
we're all actually here we're here for
the new iphone 7. so here it is
pre-orders start on september 9th and
they're available on september 16th so
it's currently september 7th so this
week is gonna get crazy so let's take a
look more at the iphone 7.
oh god you look
just real slick so it was kind of
interesting because they announced
two new colors which made it seem like
apple invented the color black i'm not
sure how it was phrased but it was kind
of comical but they have which was
originally rumored to be called piano
black but it's called jet black and then
they have sort of a matte black which
they're just calling black one of the
biggest things that was actually leaked
on twitter
on apple's own twitter account because
they bought sponsored posts i think
that's how it was happening they had
their posts pre-approved and ready to
post but if you actually went to apple's
twitter account
they weren't they weren't there so it
was kind of strange
my god i was tweeting up a storm i was
losing my freaking mind one of the most
exciting things before we get back into
more of the iphone 7 news is miyamoto
was on stage at the apple event today
and they announced a new game for ios
called super mario run and it looks like
update the android will be coming later
so it's kind of a side scrolling game
where mario just runs and you basically
just push the screen and he will jump
pretty simple but pretty awesome so i
look forward to that coming out pretty
soon for ios they also didn't mention
how much it was gonna cost so it looks
like it's gonna be a paid game and an
update here nintendo says we do intend
to release the game on android devices
at some point in the future so that
should be pretty exciting so here we go
here's a little demo and now back to our
iphone 7 updates new iphone 7 is water
resistant makes a splash takes a splash
new black and jet black finishes the new
home button an entirely new camera
enters the picture 12 megapixels optical
image stabilization 7 megapixel facetime
hd camera quad led true tone flash four
smart leds flash 50 brighter than the 6s
the flash adjusts according to the color
temperature of the environment resulting
in sharper more brightly lit photos
so this is what we've really been
looking for this is the iphone 7 plus
camera two cameras that shoot as one so
the iphone 7 doesn't have just one new
camera system it has two it's the same
12 megapixel wide angle camera that's on
the iphone 7 but it also has a telephoto
camera so you can get even closer and
there's a super cool depth of field
effect that they're calling it which if
you guys have seen any of my previous
videos where i talk about the intel
realsense i feel like it's that sort of
technology where it can sense the depth
of field so if i'm closer you're able to
pull the focus to make me more unfocused
and your background not in focus so they
said that that's a software feature that
will be coming soon so we're not sure
when so portrait shots will look better
than ever so say hello to the world's
best photo op zoom into the future
thanks for the dual camera you can get
super sharp close-up shots and videos
they didn't talk much about video
actually they talked mostly about photos
now that i'm thinking about it
there was really no mention of video at
all
i think i need to tweet about it
the brightest most colorful iphone
display yet 25 brighter the most
powerful chip ever in a smartphone it's
2x faster than the iphone 6. it's the
longest battery life ever in an iphone
so that's good iphone now in stereo it
has two speakers on the top and the
bottom earpods with lightning connector
if you guys haven't
heard there is no headphone jack on the
new iphone and they made a huge deal
about this basically saying that it
takes courage to do such a thing and to
remove such an old technology which i
agree and the lightning connector is a
much higher quality cable anyway so i
think it will work out but i need to get
a set of lightning cable headphones but
the earpods are lightning connectors and
also the air pods which are the wireless
ones will also work with not only your
iphone but it'll work with your macbook
and your um i'm the mac pro so hopefully
it'll work with that as well so here's
the earpods with a lightning connector
they will have a lightning cable adapter
so you'll be able to use a 3.5
millimeter headphone jack and just plug
it into the lightning adapter so you're
set you don't have to worry next up
we've got the air pods they're available
in late october so let's learn more
about the air pods these are going to be
really really interesting and this is
the first time that i'm getting a really
good look at it
they said that the air pods themselves
so those little guys will last five
hours but the little wireless charging
pack that you keep them in that's not
just a case that will charge them for up
to 24 hours is what i believe i read
maybe let's read some more to get the
official official news
wireless headphones finally untangled
you can tap into siri so this is kind of
cool so you'll double tap and be able to
access siri and talk to her and get
um any information like hey call my
brother brian
turn up the volume how do i get to the
zoo granted siri sometimes doesn't
really understand anything that i'm
saying so that should be interesting so
these headphones have an apple w1 chip
so it produces extremely efficient
wireless for better connection and
improved sound five hours
is not a lot of time
if you think about it that's one flight
to new york if i'm going to australia or
somewhere far away these aren't gonna
last
so it knows when you're talking a voice
accelerometer recognizes when you're
speaking and works with a pair of
beam-forming microphones to filter out
external noise it knows when you're
listening optical sensors and motion
accelerometers power of 24 hour battery
life
so
these little guys will charge it the
coolest little demo that i saw i don't
think they actually showed the demo but
they did tell you how to use it you just
open it up
place it near your iphone they didn't
announce wireless charging either did
they
i'm just having flashbacks for the live
stream and realizing that there's a lot
of stuff that they didn't mention need a
quick charge just 15 minutes of the case
gives you three hours of listening time
so that's pretty cool clearly superior
sound here's the problem with these
airpods
the earpods don't stay in my ear
so i'm having a little bit of a concern
that these aren't going to stay in my
ear either automatic setup seamless
switching i was a little skeptical at
first
i'm still a little skeptical
but i don't know so here's our current
models that we currently have we have
the iphone 7 plus iphone 7 iphone 6s
plus iphone 6s and iphone se so each
model will be available in 32 128 and
256 although the jet black again won't
be available in 32
it's pretty much
similar size to the previous models so
let's get into the prices which is what
i'm sure a lot of you guys want to know
the iphone 7 32 41 a month starting or
pay
6.49 and the iphone 7 plus let's see how
much the most expensive one is gonna
cost us oh god
that's that's expensive and it's only
8.49
only it's a hundred dollars less for the
iphone
7. so that's a quick overview of the new
iphone 7. so now let's chat about the
apple watch they announced that it's now
called the apple watch series 2 and the
previous version is going to be called
series 1. there's also the apple watch
nike edition which will be released
later this year they talked a lot about
watch os 3
but the biggest announcement was the
ceramic version so this is
really freaking pretty
now stunning in ceramic
it looks really nice
reorder september 9th available
september 16th as well
here's the nike
version
exclusive nike watch faces
nike run club and app i used to use nike
running a lot when i ran which was a
long time ago i had one of the gps
watches and it was the hardest thing to
ever get connected but they did assure
us that it was going to be super easy
and fast and just
work like that which i'm i'm hoping
that's the case because some of these
gps watches that i've tried in the past
didn't work very well so one of the
biggest things about series 2 is it has
the built-in gps which the first version
did not and it was kind of frustrating i
think for a lot of people because if you
wanted to get directions or do things
you had to have your phone connected
because it used the phone gps but now
this will have its own gps which is
incredible it's also water resistant up
to 50 meters and they showed a really
cool demo of how
uh they did the testing to make sure
that it is insured up to 50 meters
this one i've talked about it before
this one went through a full cycle in
the wash and it still worked
so
it's been wash
machine approved but one of the biggest
news and the thing that it didn't
feature on apple's website is pokemon go
is coming to the apple watch so pokemon
go will soon be available on the apple
watch they announced today at the apple
event the watch app will display how far
the player needs to walk to hatch an egg
the required experience points to reach
the next level and additional info about
the player's fitness
so you can start sort of a workout and
it'll be able to calculate how far
you've walked this is incredible i'm so
excited about it i still play pokemon go
and
i don't care what any of you say
pokestop so this kind of all makes sense
now why the pokemon go plus
wearable was delayed probably because
apple was like yo if you delay that
we'll hook you up and you guys can have
an app on the apple watch and we'll
feature you during the keynote so
it all makes sense well that was just a
quick little overview of most of the
announcements that happened today at the
apple event featuring the iphone 7 the
iphone 7 plus the apple watch series 2.
nintendo bringing out a new game for ios
coming very very soon i look forward to
hearing all of your feedback in the
comments so we can have a discussion
about what we saw what we expected what
we didn't actually
get that we were hoping that we would
get like wireless charging also some
more information about video which kind
of leads me to believe that the video
camera doesn't have much of an upgrade
because if it did they surely would have
talked about it so there's probably
nothing new in the video department with
most of the iphones maybe there is maybe
i missed it but either way that's that
and i will see you guys in my next video
if you guys are new here be sure to
subscribe so you guys can see new videos
if you like this video hit like i also
did an entire live stream of the whole
live stream so if you want to watch that
i'll put a link in the description it's
long potentially could be boring
but i'm not really sure but i'll see you
guys later hope you guys have a great
day welcome to my apple event live
stream we're here we're live streaming
we're live and over
here
i have a bunch of tweets so these are
all set up to curate all the tweets you
guys send me during the event and be
sure to use the